police are describing this as a
fast-moving investigation at this
address in north london where officers
are carrying out searches they've
established a crime scene
the focus is now on the capitol where
the suspect ali harby alley lived
the 25 year old british national who's
of somali descent is in police custody
where he's being held under terror
legislation
a short distance away at his father's
home detectives have been arriving 61
year old harby ali khalani is helping
them with their inquiries
the former director of communications
for the prime minister of somalia has
told sky news he's traumatized by events
neighbours describe this area as a
typical london suburb we live in the
fourth year we never have any problem
but people keep to themselves you don't
really know they say hello like every
neighbor say hello to each other you
know it's very quiet quiet road everyone
knows each other
and we all get along we're like a
community a lot of people here have
lived here for a very long time
and investigators are also still at the
scene of the crime in leon c
it's now known the suspect made an
appointment to cesar david amos on the
day he was killed
the 69 year old mp was stabbed multiple
times whilst holding a surgery for his
constituents
the police have formally declared the
attack an act of terrorism here in
london the searches are continuing
throughout the day there has been
an extensive police presence at this
property now investigators say they're
not looking for anyone else in
connection with the murder
the assumption by the security services
is that this was a lone wolf attacker
who had self-radicalized
according to whitehall sources ali
harvey ali had been referred in the past
to the prevent scheme it's a government
program to stop radicalization
and he's currently being questioned at a
specialist unit in london for terror
suspects after being moved from a police
station in essex they'll be doing a lot
of intelligence work to find out a bit
more about this individual uh where
they've come from who they might be
connected to and just to make sure
they're not part of any wider plot from
which we could see a residual action
they'll also be monitoring uh lots of
other channels to listen to the chatter
and just to see whether these sorts of
actions have a mobilizing effect on
other would-be um terrorists so that act
that action will be going on in the
background in collaboration with the
security services
as tributes continue to be laid the
murder will undoubtedly lead to changes
in the way mps perform their duties
greater police protection is among the
measures being considered to keep
politicians safe whilst they meet their
constituents
alex rossi sky news
north london